explíquenos un poco cuáles son las
implicaciones en la economía rusa de
congelar las acciones de empresas y de
oligarcas
para clara cómo estás muchas gracias por
la invitación
pues
obviamente aquí hay una serie de medidas
que se han venido tomando tal vez las
más importantes que te pones a tomar en
este fin de semana fueron la de excluir
a varios bancos del sistema swift que es
el sistema de telecomunicaciones
para que los bancos hagan transacciones
internacionales con el resto del mundo y
la segunda tal vez muy importante es la
que tiene que ver con el congelamiento
de transacciones que puede hacer el
banco central de rusia con las reservas
internacionales de tal forma que no
puede vender los las reservas
internacionales que tiene para por
ejemplo entre otras cosas depender él
el rubro
entonces estos son tal vez las dos más
significativas que realmente tienen un
impacto
importante sobre la economía rusa
digamos que ya hay un precedente de lo
que esto puede lo que esto puede
impactar por ejemplo a irán le hicieron
la
sanción a los bancos del sistema swift
ya raíz de eso las exportaciones de irán
cayeron en un monto muy importante por
ejemplo las exportaciones de petróleo
cayeron un 30 por ciento los medios
siguientes después de las sanciones
entonces un poco lo que se está lo que
se está procurando acá es generar un
impacto muy fuerte sobre la economía
rusa de tal forma que obviamente es rusa
russia desista de las
medidas militares que está tomando en
este momento pero las otras medidas las
que tomaron la semana pasada antes del
fin de semana y las que se tengan hoy
pues simplemente son complementos
y algunas de estas medidas importantes
están tratando de generar un impacto
importante sobre la economía y cómo
puede reaccionar el kremlin para
proteger precisamente a la economía y a
su banco central
bueno eso es precisamente la dificultad
que tiene en las medidas que se están
tomando ahora una cosa importante de las
reservas internacionales que tiene el
banco central de rusia que son más o
menos unos 700 mil millones de dólares
la mitad lo más uno son los trescientos
y pico mil millones de dólares están
denominados en dos en oro perdón y
también en reservas que están
denominadas en la moneda china entonces
digamos que por ese lado si hay cierto
cierta forma en el cual en la cual se
pueden hacer algunas algunas operaciones
pero digamos que la operación más
importante en últimas la moneda más
transada en el mundo pues es el dólar la
mayoría del comercio internacional se
hace en dólares entonces es básicamente
de la noche a la mañana rusia perdió más
o menos la mitad de las reservas
internacionales que tienen o sea unos
350 mil millones de dólares que no
tienen dólares que puede que podría
antes que podía antes usar para hacer
intervenciones del mercado cambiar
discúlpame interrumpo pero no lo quiero
dejar ir sin hacerle esta pregunta y es
cuál es la repercusión que todo esto
puede tener en los mercados de américa
latina
pues hay varios canales de transmisión
tal vez el más importante que estamos
viendo en este momento tiene que ver con
los precios de las materias primas a
raíz de esto pues digamos que rusia
siendo un productor importante de
petróleo y de gas pues ha tenido un
impacto importante al alza en esos dos
mercados
también es un producto muy importante de
granos y además es un exportador muy
importante fertilizantes entonces aquí
hay unos unos unos impactos un poco
mixtos por el lado de las materias
primas como ya lo dije por ejemplo el
tema del petróleo hay un efecto que
podría ser beneficioso para algunas
algunas economías latinoamericanas como
es el caso por ejemplo de medido con
mucho caso de colombia que son
exportadores netos pero el caso por el
de chile que es un importador nuestro
petróleo pues obviamente el impacto que
tendría a ser negativo pero en últimas
también esto pues tiene un impacto sobre
las monedas hasta el momento
afortunadamente el impacto ha sido
relativamente contenido a los monedas
latinoamericanas al comienzo sufrir un
poco de devaluación pero por la subida
de los de las materias primas las
monedas también se han se han visto
beneficiadas en la última en las últimas
dos sesiones
ahora hay otro impacto importante y es
que a raíz de la subida de los precios
de las materias primas y también de
estos insumos los granos por ejemplo y
los fertilizantes que ya dije que rus es
un gran productor de fertilizantes de
ucrania también eso tiene un impacto
sobre todo en los precios de los
alimentos a nivel internacional y en la
américa latina y también son el precio
de la gasolina eso va a implicar una
inflación posible más alta en américa
latina y posiblemente va a hacer que los
bancos centrales en la región que ya han
tenido que subir las tasas de interés de
manera muy importante van a tener que
reaccionar con una subida de tasas de
interés mucho más agresivas